okay so as I've told you before the real
story the quote real story with Donald
Trump and stormy Daniels is not whether
Melania Trump knew that Trump was having
an affair or didn't know it's not
whether Trump used a condom as
interesting as I know that that's become
for a lot of people in our audience I've
seen the email some don't care some do
the really important part of the stormy
Daniels story is the possibly coercive
nature of these non-disclosure
agreements that are being used and
number two the potential illegality of
the hundred and thirty thousand dollars
in hush money that stormy Daniels was
paid there are a few different ways that
the hush money might have been illegal
the story were being told is that
because Michael Cohen likes Donald Trump
so much out of his friendship for Donald
Trump out of his genuine love for his
client Donald Trump he decided to cut a
check to stormy Daniels for a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars out of his
own money merely to get her to go away
and not talk about what of course they
maintain is a totally fake allegation of
an affair and he never even asked Donald
Trump for reimbursement to the hundred
and thirty thousand dollars and where it
gets really unbelievable is that Trump
is a billionaire how how many times over
there's disagreement about but I guess
we believe that Trump is a billionaire
Michael Cohen had to mortgage his house
or like get a home equity line of credit
in order to get that hundred and thirty
thousand dollars that he gave to stormy
Daniels and supposedly Donald Trump
never paid coming back maybe because he
had no idea about this it's laughable
right any clear-thinking person
recognizes that this makes no sense
whatsoever there is no chance in hell
that when your clients a billionaire you
just love him so much
that instead of just asking him to
reimburse you for the hundred and thirty
thousand dollars you mortgage your house
and never tell Donald Trump about it
it's totally not believable but Michael
Cohen's lawyer Cohen himself has
lawyered up right so Trump's lawyer is
Cohen Cohen has a lawyer named David
Schwartz David Schwartz has been going
around
any show that will listen that this is
the story no matter what logic dictates
and David Schwartz was interviewed on
the megan kelly
daily program the daytime program for
all my criticisms about megyn kelly and
this pretty stupid daily show that he
has she made David Schwartz look really
really stupid when he told this story
about a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars paid out of love by Michael
Cohen and it was so bad that at one
point the entire audience is just
laughing at the guy let's look at the
video it's worth seeing the whole way
through to just see how every time he
says it megyn kelly shows the total lack
of credibility that this story has in
business okay it's true but the weird
thing about this case is that Michael
Cohen signed the deal Donald Trump
didn't and you are claiming that Michael
Cohen the president's lawyer and fixer
ray Donovan character never ever told
Donald Trump about it never never never
told him and Michael Cohen dispensed
$130,000 of his own money and never
sought reimbursement from Donald Trump
under percent so the whitby no one
believes that okay yes and the dynamics
of the relationship it was not has
billions of dollars if Michael Cohen
doesn't let me finish my let me Michael
Cohen does have millions of dollars okay
zillions so no millions and billions all
right let me finish my answer okay
Michael Michael Cohen had great
authority within that organization gotta
take care of that I'm talking about the
so now the money you got to see the way
this all comes down first of all he got
approached okay he got approached 19
days or 15 days before the election okay
he got approached it'll take a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars makers up to
it to make this go away he had to make a
decision okay not even challenge I'm
challenging one on the impossibility
it's not that he paid 130 grand for
something he didn't do and never sorry
your birthday for a client when you're
looking at in the vacuum like when but
if you understand the relationship here
it makes complete sense that he's
approached am I going to go to the boss
or am I not going to go to the boss all
right what do I
- he chose not to go to the ball he
chose to take care of this that I
wouldn't he get 130 why would he pay 130
grand of his own money yeah well you
know what you're gonna when Michael
Cohen does come out you're gonna you're
gonna find out the mechanics of that
they're dodging you're getting that
balance I am answer what's the truth the
what the truth is he loves he loves the
boss and he all right who believes this
right and megyn kelly doing a really
good job here of showing that the story
they're telling is ridiculous and by the
way it's still not clear that Cohen
wasn't reimbursed I'm guessing at some
point we will learn that Michael Cohen
was reimbursed for those hundred and
thirty thousand dollars and we will find
out in what way it was done the term we
have to apply here is called Trump's
razor Josh Marshall from Talking Points
Memo and sci-fi writer John Scalzi sort
of together one or both of them built up
and promoted this term you've got
Occam's razor right I love this Occam's
razor simply is if you've got two
explanations for the same occurrence the
simpler one is usually better or more
accurate or set another way the the
explanation for a phenomena that
requires fewer assumptions is generally
the better one sort of like the simplest
explanation is generally the one that we
should prefer or gravitate to not always
true but it's an AI it's a principle
Trump's razor is if you have two
competing explanations for an occurrence
the one that implies the stupidest
behavior by Trump in his cronies is the
one that you go with and by the time
that this is all said and done I think
we might end up with another instance of
that here which is that of all the
different ways in which the stormy
Daniel situation could have been handled
the one that directly implies the
highest degree of stupidity from Donald
Trump and everybody working for him is
the one that ultimately will be the true
one and that might include illegal
payments that might include instances of
absolute and sheer idiocy and David
Schwartz truly gutted here I mean
embarrassingly so by Meghan Kelly in
this interview their claims are falling
apart
every time we learn a little bit more
about Michael Cohen the more he seems
genuinely like a mafia thug type
character working for Donald Trump and I
don't believe for a moment that Trump is
just totally in the dark about what it
is that's going on discuss this with us
on our subreddit at david pakman.com
slash re d di t I wanted to talk about
this yesterday but didn't have time last
week after weeks and weeks of not taking
questions in a press conference after
days of having nothing public on his
calendar whatsoever Trump decided to do
basically a campaign rally he went to
Ohio to do a rally in front of a
friendly crowd it's kind of like what
you do when you're running for president
supposedly it was going to be an
infrastructure speech by the way how
often is it infrastructure week it seems
like almost every week in this
administration is infrastructure week
Trump went completely and totally off
the rails it turned into a very strange
garbled rant resembling the English
language only loosely and demonstrating
a sort of Sarah Palin like inability to
communicate anything of meaning through
language and it got so bad that the
three major cable networks CNN MSNBC and
Fox News Paul just cut away from the
speech although you'll be pleased to
know that good old Fox Business Network
stayed with the entire thing all the way
through here is Fox bailing when it got
weird former george w bush white house
press secretary dana perino who's now a
fox news anchor fittingly explaining
that they are going away and she looked
sort of in physical pain as she said it
32,000 soldiers are even watching
president Russell is in Ohio giving a
speech wide-ranging speech but mostly
focusing on his infrastructure plan and
former White House deputy chief of staff
Karl Rove is back with me I like that
wide-ranging is code for Trump is all
over the place real quick go to Karl
Rove to try to say this it save us here
so even Fox cutting away even though
they did stay with it a few minutes
longer than CNN and mint and MSNBC so
here just random weird moments the
entire speech was totally off the rails
all right here's just a random 20
seconds of Trump from this speech we're
a very important
and respected in some circles Democrat
said we want to get rid we should get
rid of our Second Amendment in other
words get rid of it that's really good
it could be right about that so we're
going to protect our Second Amendment
that's not going to happen we have the
best judges we put on a tremendous
amount of great Federal District Court
judges will be setting records we are
setting records appeals court judges
Supreme Court judge fantastic justice
Gorsuch what is he talking about setting
records like what what the hell is this
guy on just another few seconds from
Trump's bizarre speech that networks
couldn't even stay with and we didn't
have one Democrat who voted they want to
raise your taxes and they want people to
come in from the border and they want I
guess want I can't imagine they want but
certainly drugs are flowing across
borders we need walls we started
building our wall I'm so proud of it
I started we started we have 1.6 billion
and we've already started you saw the
pictures yesterday I said what a thing
of beauty and on September 28th we go
further yeah that was a lie by the way
the pictures he's referring to were from
the replacement of two miles of border
fence dating back to the 1990s we've got
one more clip again just disjointed
rantings of a madman we spent and I was
against it from the beginning they try
and say well maybe not I was against it
from the beginning and by the way we're
knocking the hell out of Isis will be
coming out of Syria like very soon let
the other people take care of it now
very soon very soon we're coming out
we're gonna have a hundred percent of
the Caliphate as they call it sometimes
referred to as land take it all back
quickly quickly
but we're gonna be coming out of there
real soon gonna get back to our country
where we belong where we want to be but
just think of it we spent as of three
months ago
seven trillion dollars not billion not
million seven trillion with the T nobody
ever heard of the word trillion until 10
years ago we spent seven trillion
dollars in the Middle East we'd build a
school that blow it up we'd build it
again they'd blow it up we'd build it
again
has it been blown up yet but it will be
but if we want to school in Ohio to fix
the windows you can't get the money if
you want a school in Pennsylvania or
Iowa to get federal money you can't get
the money we spent seven trillion
dollars in the middle east and you know
we have for it nothing remember I used
to say keep the oil as a civilian
I used to say did anybody hear me say
that that's before I decided to go in
this journey with all of you I got tired
of watching what on earth is this guy
talking about i it is the disjointed
rantings of someone who understands
nothing it's always infrastructure week
or month or whatever nothing actually
happens except Trump just showing up and
talking about his random random musings
here and it's there's two phases of a
Trump speech there's the horrible syntax
of the teleprompter reading where he's
looking off at an angle and saying and
if we were to become a better nation of
and then we would write like it's just
he can't read it it just makes no sense
whatsoever and then you see when he
shifts off the teleprompter and look
straight ahead and but then you don't
even know what the guy's talking about
because he's just completely off the
rails and improvising and I hope that
soon we actually get a press conference
supposedly he's doing one today
questions like mr. president can you
just say definitively did you have sex
with stormy Daniels did you realize that
your people were knowingly and directly
dealing with Russian intelligence
officers did you know about the hundred
and thirty thousand dollars that Michael
Cohen paid stormy Daniels have you
reimbursed some specific questions and
you can't put him out there because he
could end up saying something horribly
self incriminating so I hope we get a
press conference
soon these speeches are but so bizarre
that even FoxNews had to cut away from
them even if he did get those questions
though I think he would go off on a
tangent about how he won the 2016
election it was greatest victory of all
time
baby got to deflect maybe he would but I
think he would very likely end up saying
something totally totally self
incriminating and it's pretty clear
they're trying to keep him away from
those types of questions hopefully he
will get some today bizarre speech that
a lot of people on our subreddit noticed
and you can join that discussion if you
can stomach it at david pakman.com slash
re d di t if I tell you that someone
talked sense on Fox News you would
immediately know that it was either
shepard smith or less likely but
possibly chris wallace someone talked
sense on fox news yesterday insta
fact-checking Donald Trump's bogus
claims about Amazon and Jeff Bezos
straight-up telling his audience none of
what you heard was true and it was
indeed Shep Smith let's check it out
we're gonna start with Donald Trump's
claims about Amazon and their deal with
the post office that Trump completely
misunderstood he also took aim today
again today at Amazon the post office is
losing billions of dollars and the
taxpayers are paying for that money
because it delivers packages for Amazon
at a very below cost and that's not fair
to the United States it's not fair to
our taxpayers and Amazon has the money
to pay the fair rate at the post which
would be much more than their thing
right now we're giving a subsidy to
Amazon and we're talking about billions
of dollars a year but the real cost and
a report just came out they said a
dollar 47 I believe or about that for
every time they deliver a package the
United States government meaning the
post office loses $1 47 so Amazon is
gonna have to pay much more money to the
post office yeah okay so that stuff is
not true it's just not but usually you
don't hear that fact-checked on Fox News
but look at Shep Smith go the Postal
Service's own numbers show it makes
money by delivering packages for Amazon
and other company
as for taxpayers the post offices own
website points out and I quote the
Postal Service receives no tax dollars
for operating expenses none and that
reference to a dollar 47 that the
president came up with their a Citigroup
study last year showed on average the
Postal Service was charging a dollar 46
below market rates for package delivery
but our researchers point out if that
discount exists it's not just for Amazon
it's a bulk rate discount back to John
Roberts there is a great deal of
confusion or something here regarding
Amazon in the post office because none
of that none of that was in it was true
that's right it's just not true and it's
too complicated to explain to Trump and
the entire Amazon package delivery world
is super interesting aside from whether
we like or dislike Amazon as a company
aside from whether Trump gets it there's
a lot of really interesting stuff Amazon
does they have huge market power they
strike deals with UPS and FedEx and the
post office they purchase a fleet of
planes to do some of their own shipping
it's all really interesting but as far
as what Trump is saying the bottom line
is that USPS offers $1 47 bulk rate
discount from market rates it's not
necessarily a loss it's just a discount
it's not just for Amazon and the reason
for all of this stuff is partially that
Trump just doesn't like Jeff Bezos
because Bezos owns the Washington Post
and The Washington Post has been doing
really good critical investigative
journalism related to Trump's
administration and then behind all of
this is probably the idea as we'll touch
on with Corey Dugan next week when he's
back on the show that Trump would love
to privatize USPS to some degree the way
he wanted to privatize the VA and just
likes the idea of privatization but I
don't want to get hugely off track I've
explained this before the biggest reason
that conservatives say we should
privatize the post office is because on
paper they're not doing well financially
which is because they are required to
pre-fund something like the next 50 or
75 years of retirement benefits for
employees which is absurd I'm forgetting
the exact details offhand but in any
case it's it's it's Trump likes to call
it this was a Nancy Pelosi beauty or an
Obama
Beauty it's a right wing beauty to
constantly go back and talk about
privatizing the post office and that
that's just something that I don't see
happening anytime soon people wondering
how does Shep Smith get away with this
stuff a couple possibilities-- he might
have an ironclad contract I don't know
about that the other possibility is that
it's sort of calculated by Fox they say
listen what we're gonna let Shep say
whatever he wants the rest of the
network is complete right-wing lunacy
and then anytime we get called out we
can always say listen we've got a range
of opinions on the show we've got all
this stuff and then we've got Shep Smith
and they can sort of use Shep to try to
deny their bias ultimately it's very
very fun to watch the trumpet's go into
cognitive dissonance shock how how can
Shep be doing this how can any of this
stuff be true they're disrupting my echo
chamber yeah and you know Trump takes
everything he hears on Fox News is
gospel true so maybe this will cause him
to reevaluate his position on this maybe
he'll figure out that he was wrong about
Amazon in the post office
my sense is he's just not watching Shep
Smith I don't know I've never even heard
Trump mentioned awareness of Shep Smith
at any time so I think it's mostly Fox
and Friends and Hannity that Trump is uh
sort of paying attention to let's take a
quick break Amanda Marcotte joins me
next I love this story the Catholic
Church and the Vatican are now
scrambling after Pope Francis sort of
appeared to question whether there even
is a hell which is kind of a pretty
basic belief of Catholicism but you
don't have to worry because the flunkies
are claiming he was just misunderstood
what happened is that during a recent
meeting Eugenio Scalf re who's the now
93 year old founder of a Vatican
newspaper asked Pope Francis where do
bad Souls go of course the correct
answer in the context of the Catholic
Church is supposed to be while they go
to hell and Pope Francis is quoted by
Scalf re as saying quote they are not
punished those who repent obtain God's
forgiveness and take their place among
the ranks of those who contemplate him
but those who do not repent and cannot
be forgiven disappear a hell doesn't
exist
the
disappearance of sinning souls exists
this led to panic at the Vatican that
should be a name for a funny romantic
comedy panic at the Vatican and if
you're the Vatican you you sort of need
the threat of eternity in hell to get
people to fall in line right this is one
of the ways in which you get people to
do what you want them to do is convince
them that if they don't do what you want
them to do that they're gonna end up
spending an eternity in hell they are
writing this off as a misquote but
they're not even offering an alternative
meaning they're just saying quote of the
Pope are not accurate the Vatican said
that the quote literal words pronounced
by the Pope are not quoted and that
quote no quotation of the article should
be considered as a faithful
transcription of the words of the Holy
Father then the other interpretation
explaining what's going on here is that
what he meant
isn't that hell doesn't exist but that
hell as a place of fire and brimstone
and misery isn't real like there's no
hell if you imagine the burning Inferno
but there is how if it's just separation
from God and the disappearance of the
soul or something like that but then
you're really finding an explanation it
just fit what it was that was allegedly
said here the problem with that is that
there are endless poor trails of Hell by
Catholics as exactly a place of fire and
brimstone in their own scriptures in the
book of Revelation in Corinthians anyway
I don't really care about the specifics
I just love how this Pope who is from
Argentina by the way has thrown the
Catholic Church into these moments of
chaos as a result of just steering away
even slightly from some of the orthodoxy
of the church and the one sort of caveat
here is that the interviewer Scalf re
Eugenio Scalf re he does have somewhat
of a history of being I guess I'll call
it fast and loose with the truth in some
cases but it still seems weird that he
would make up an interview whole cloth
for both from a sort of marketing and PR
perspective for his newspaper and from a
legal perspective but this is a super
interest
because we've been following the move
away from Catholicism that's been going
on you've seen people leaving
Catholicism because they've stopped
being religious altogether right like
that's one layer which is in general
particularly younger generations are
becoming less and less religious over
time but there's this whole other angle
which is that there are Catholics who
have also just left Catholicism and
moved to Protestantism meaning non
Catholic Christianity and part of it has
to do with the specifics of the Catholic
Church and it's sort of feeling quite
frankly there was one of those possible
bingo phrases quite frankly like a dated
and sort of in in downfall organization
even though they still have like 1.2 1.3
billion adherents so it's gonna be an
interesting decade I think for the
Catholic Church up coming yeah and I
think that's why we're seeing such a
progressive Pope in Pope Francis I mean
the guy seems to be okay with gay
marriage he accepts that climate change
exists it's just interesting how saying
that hell doesn't exist is a bridge too
far for these Catholics yeah and there's
the last straw we can't have that
straight-up panicking and saying that's
simply not what he said send me your
thoughts I know that there are current
and ex Catholics in the show audience
and I'd be interested in hearing from
them for sure slowly reluctantly
eventually Donald Trump joined dozens of
other countries in expelling Russian
diplomats because of Russian involvement
in a nerve agent poisoning in the United
Kingdom and we were told yes
Trump has done it 60 Russian diplomats
suspected of being spies and
intelligence agents under diplomatic
cover they are out it is tough
punishment for Russia we're now learning
it's not that Donald Trump has reduced
the number of Russian diplomats that are
allowed in the United States by 60 in
other words it's not that these 60 left
and that's it the total number of
Russian spies in the u.s. goes down by
60 Russia can just send back 60 other
people in other words Trump has forced
60 specific people to leave and 60 more
are coming and this bit of news
originally made the rounds after the
assertion was made on Russian language
television but it's now been confirmed
by the State Department or in
l from the USA Today Network broke this
in the United States with a tweet early
in the weekend where he said I asked the
State Department about this and it's
true
Trump's expulsion this week of 60
Russian diplomats does not require
Russia to reduce its staffing levels in
the US and vice versa Russia can simply
send 60 new diplomats to replace the
other 60 this is a show and nothing else
it's not like those 60 people they
expelled were specifically suspected of
being responsible for the nerve attack
in the United States it's just 60 people
are out and 60 people are coming back in
and it appears by the way that the same
conditions apply to the United States
right the diplomats kicked out of Russia
by Putin it seems the US can also just
send 60 more there it is a complete and
total farce well you know how we've
talked about how Trump can't seem to
fill the positions at the State
Department and that there are so many
vacancies there yeah well going
unconfirmed maybe he thinks that this is
the ultimate form of punishment I mean
how are you gonna fill 60 seats right
for trumpet actually is gonna be pretty
tough the guys got hundreds of positions
that are open anyway so Russia's gonna
be forced to change out 60 of their
intelligence officers in the US and it's
almost creating more work for American
intelligence because we kick out 60
Russian diplomats that we already
suspect or know or spies because of the
intelligence work that we've done now
Russia sends 60 new people which
American intelligence resources have to
vet from the beginning and learn about
it it's totally bizarro world alternate
universe backwards situation a farce
call it what you want
the next observation to be made the next
sort of issue to explore when it comes
to this is what is going to be the
impact of john bolton as national
security advisor right what influence is
he going to have on trump's russia
policy and i've talked to you last week
when we learned that HR McMaster is out
as trump ii national security adviser
and john bolton is taking over a week
from today as trump's third national
security adviser john bolton is the
ultimate hawk on almost any geopolitical
issue whether it's Iran
architect of the Iraq war there's been
no shortage of places that John Bolton
would have loved to see military action
against that is going to be interesting
because Bolton is also known as more of
a hawk on the issue of Russia and you've
got on the one hand John Bolton and then
on the other hand you've got Donald
Trump who has been arguably the softest
on Russia Russia being the exception to
Trump's wrath wrath wrath that has been
very widespread across diplomats all
over the world except for the really
authoritarian ones which seem to be the
ones that Donald Trump sort of admires
the most and gets along with the most
what will happen within the White House
once you have John Bolton in there
presumably telling Trump the way he sees
it on the issue of Russia which is
certainly not with the deference that
we've seen from Donald Trump for the
first 1415 months of the presidency but
for the time being the expulsion of the
diplomats just another charade just
another total farce and gong show with
absolutely no real consequence and I'm
curious to see how it continues send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show boy do we have a good show for you
today
there's a really interesting story going
on with Fox News host Laura Ingraham
that I want to spend a little time
talking about with you today a Laura
Ingraham you might remember was brought
into Fox News as a host sort of during
and throughout the shake-up involving a
number of hosts she was a fill-in for a
while off and on for Bill O'Reilly who
eventually left Fox in total shame after
multiple sexual assault allegations and
settlements other hosts came in and out
and eventually she got herself a show
called the Ingraham angle and she's
horrible like truly truly horrible she's
known for when she was in high school
she wrote a letter to the parent of some
classmate outing them as gay because she
didn't like that and found out that they
were involved in some group on campus I
don't even remember the story maybe
she's apologized maybe she hasn't but
she's got a lot of really horrible stuff
in her past and most recently she's
gotten into trouble because she
criticized victims of the parkland
Florida mass school shooting and a lot
of people didn't like it
and specifically david hog who's one of
the students who's been more publicly
seen as an activist around gun safety
after the shooting she tweeted or he
tweeted rather that he had been rejected
from four universities and that ingram
accused him of whining about it and
laura Ingram's
tweet about this was david hog rejected
by four colleges to which he applied and
whines about it dinged by UCLA with a
4.1 GPA totally predictable given
acceptance rates now it might not seem
like that big of a deal but this is a
powerful corporate media host who's
going on twitter and making fun of a kid
who didn't get into college as a kid who
has made himself publicly known after
the parkland Florida shooting and david
hog tweeted back calling for a boycott
of laura Ingram's advertisers saying so
ingram angle laura ingram what are your
biggest advertisers asking for a friend
hashtag boycotting boycotting gramm
adverts and this got a lot of people to
start calling for boycotts of the long
list of companies that advertise or
advertise to past-tense on laura
ingraham show and many of those
companies have announced we're not going
to advertise with laura ingram anymore
and the companies include Home Depot
Hulu TripAdvisor Expedia Johnson &
Johnson Liberty Mutual Liberty Mutual I
am a customer of I tweeted to them
saying pull your ads from Laura Ingraham
and then of course after nearly a dozen
advertisers or more said we're not
advertising with her anymore she put out
an apology clearly completely out of
necessity due to the disastrous press
around the time where she said any
student should be proud of a 4.2 GPA
including david hog on reflection in the
spirit of holy week pandering to the
religious people i apologized for any
upset or hurt my tweet caused him or any
of the brave victims of parkland for the
record i believe my show was the first
to feature david and then she goes on to
just try to pander and now lo and behold
laura ingram is on a week vacation the
speculation is that this was not a
planned vacation just like when bill
o'reilly was sent on a vacay
when advertisers started bailing before
he was pulled out here's Laura Ingraham
announcing this I'll be off next week
for Easter break with my kids but fear
not we've got a great lineup of guest
host to fill in for me yeah so the
obvious question is was it a planned
vacation or is this a forced vacation
she didn't mention it before is this the
beginning of a Bill O'Reilly type firing
so listen I would love to see her lose
her show because it's a terrible show
and it spreads disinformation the real
issue I want to talk about is that as
soon as I tweeted to Liberty Mutual
saying please drop Laura Ingraham and
ultimately Liberty Mutual did drop Laura
Ingraham people started tweeting to me
saying David don't you defend free
speech shouldn't Laura Ingraham be
allowed to say whatever it is that she
wants why is she being persecuted and
punished for what she said and of course
this is a very common misunderstanding
of free speech Laura Ingraham is free to
say whatever she wants wherever she
wants to say it provided that her
employer Fox News says that she can say
whatever she wants on air and it seems
they hired her to be controversial and
she can tweet whatever the hell she
wants but free speech doesn't mean that
there can be no consequences to that
speech Ingraham has free speech rights
to say what she wants every single
FoxNews viewer Twitter user can react to
that speech by saying I like it or I
don't like it or I'm going to lobby her
advertisers to stop advertising on her
show that is them utilizing their free
speech
now then people could come to me and say
but David someone could unfairly target
the david pakman show Zaid ver tais errs
including your new ones like shaker and
spoon and brilliant whoever else and my
answer would be that's right they could
I can say whatever I want my viewers can
say whatever they want to my advertisers
and my advertisers can also use whatever
information is important to them to say
we are or aren't going to advertise on
the David Pakman show that is how it
works
no one's free speech is being violated
no one is being censored there's no
government or law enforcement
intervention in anyone's speech
whatsoever everybody gets to say what
they want sort of direct incitement to
violence which is my view on free speech
and everyone gets to make the personal
decisions the business decisions about
what they
watch where their company advertises I
could be hurt by the same tactics that
are hurting laura ingraham but i can't
be a hypocrite no one is doing anything
wrong so what is there for me to be
against now should Fox News fire her
listen Fox News hired her knowing that
she had all sorts of horrible statements
in her past my instinct is that they're
not gonna fire her for what she said but
if the show no longer makes money
because Fox is a for-profit company then
all of a sudden they might say well this
is no longer of use to us and she's
gonna have to go they may keep her
around too because the turnover there is
already so high I mean we can't afford
to lose another Fox host sure we've
already lost Bill O'Reilly and Yahoo
Carlson and megyn kelly list goes on and
on
sure yeah I mean maybe as a staffing
thing they might keep her but in in
terms of the arguments around free
speech and censorship and all of this
other stuff come on I am no hypocrite I
have the exact same standard for her as
I do for me and I would have to deal
with the consequences if I said
something really offensive and people
lobbied my advertisers to drop the show
we have yet another Trump appointee who
sadly while I guess sadly for him good
for the country is resigning from his
job this time because of the revelation
that he was posting crazy birther
nonsense to his Facebook page Todd
Johnson is his name he ran New Mexico
for the Trump campaign back in 2016 he
got a job at the Department of Defense
last year that already is kind of weird
he was hired at the gs-14 pay level
which is usually for quite senior civil
service positions we don't know why
Johnson was hired at that level but in
any case CNN started looking into this
guy and they found that he had posted a
whole bunch of birther conspiracies
about Barack Obama he shared videos that
claimed Barack Obama was the Antichrist
to his Facebook page and yet again we
are a laughingstock right Johnson was
working alongside the defense secretary
Jim mattis
he would travel with mattis this is not
once again I'm using this term Johnson
was not some coffee boy he was a gs-14
Department of Defense employee working
directly with the Secretary of Defense
Jim mattis and some of the videos that
Johnson shared to Facebook include one
called
Michelle Obama admits Barack Obama's
home country is Kenya
friend of Johnson's commented that Obama
being a Muslim makes him crazy - which
Johnson replied yes sir and Johnson also
shared a story that joked about Obama
being murdered after a crash of Air
Force One in rural Kentucky why are
there different standards for different
people
so Todd Johnson has been forced to
resign because he was parroting birther
nonsense on Facebook wasn't Trump kind
of the birther in chief Trump made
birther statements and was elected
president and Johnson posted some stuff
to Facebook and he's forced to resign a
birther resigned from the Department of
Defense but the de facto public leader
of the birther movement is the President
of the United States
Trump bragged about sexually assaulting
women and he was elected president Billy
Bush laughed about it in the same
recording and lost his job at Access
Hollywood Trump slammed Hillary Clinton
for her handling of sensitive
information as a reason she shouldn't be
elected president and then Trump gives
away secrets from an ally to Russian
spies in the Oval Office and the
committed Trump estill defend the guy
and for those who saying well listen
Trump doesn't believe the birther stuff
anymore
that's what it appears to be at the end
of 2017 I told you this was only five
months ago that it was widely reported
that Trump privately was still saying
he's not sure about the legitimacy of
Obama's infamous long-form birth
certificate and we found out about it
because some of the people in the room
were so distraught over the fact that
Trump was still talking about this
that they felt it necessary to leak word
of those conversations to the media now
I genuinely don't know why Todd Johnson
has had to resign because it just
there's no evidence that this is a
disqualifier there's no evidence that
being a birther makes any difference
when the president believed that stuff
and was still elected I just don't get
it just different standards I guess well
maybe it's because Todd Johnson joked
about the president getting killed the
president being Obama of course and that
Obama was the Antichrist I mean that
seems to me like it's clearly hyperbole
whereas the birtherism stuff was a
conspiracy theory for sure but still
somewhat mainstream if people like Trump
are going to support it yeah I mean
think it's a distinction but it's not
not really a difference and you know
we're not gonna dig into the birther
stuff anymore but I still don't get why
it even matters where Obama was born
since his mom was unquestionably
American like whether Obama was born in
London or Indonesia or Kenya or wherever
the birthers are still wrong in
principle on the entire thing but I
think at this point the ship has sailed
okay big breaking news story according
to the Kremlin Donald Trump has invited
Vladimir Putin to the White House and
you might say well who cares we should
want better relationships with Russia we
should want to be Russia's friend this
is great
yay and then we get back to reality and
we learned that this reportedly happened
during that same phone call a couple of
weeks ago where after being told do not
congratulate Vladimir Putin on his sham
election win Donald Trump did exactly
that congratulated Vladimir Putin on his
win mentioned nothing about election
meddling mentioned nothing about the
continued suspicious deaths of Russian
dissidents around the world and the
claim about this invitation to maybe
come to the White House for Vladimir
Putin came from a Kremlin aide named
Yuri ochakov who said that Russian who
said to Russian journalists that quote
if everything will be alright I hope
that the Americans will not back away
from their own proposal to discuss the
possibility of holding a summit when our
president spoke on the phone it was
Trump who proposed holding the first
meeting in Washington in the White House
Putin hasn't been to the White House
since 2005 when george w bush was
president when the US and russia I guess
sort of had a better relationship you
could say so why do we care well we care
because this is Vladimir Putin's
manipulation of Donald Trump bearing
fruit right it's another example of
Putin getting what he wants which is be
being seen as a sort of serious world
leader that gets invited and the red
carpet is rolled out for them and they
get to go into the most special of
places although certainly the white the
Oval Office has become less special
since Donald Trump has appropriated it
what better situation for Putin
than a long in-person meeting with Trump
on Trump's own turf were Putin who is
very skilled will use his skills to
manipulate Trump and even even when you
look at how we found out about this
right even the release of this news by
Russia is part of the ploy to embarrass
Trump and just create chaos because now
it's win-win for Vladimir Putin if Trump
admits yeah I I did say that he could
come to the White House well why wasn't
it mentioned and why would Trump do it
and why would he reward Russia with
inviting Vladimir Putin to the White
House and then if Trump denies it it
immediately calls into question whether
Trump is lying something that he does a
lot and if so it would make us wonder
why is this something that Trump would
lie about which only increases more of
the suspicions about what's going on
with Russia the fact that we're first
hearing about this from Russia is sort
of part of the chaos that Russia is so
expertly catalyzing and we once again
we've got to apply Trump's razor to this
as I mentioned yesterday no matter what
you believe the limits of geopolitical
stupidity to be the current
administration the Trump administration
will act in the most ignorant and stupid
way possible to the point that you will
be shocked and in fact the most likely
scenario is that we get initially a
denial from the Trump administration
followed by a White House visit by
Vladimir Putin and then there will never
actually be a follow-up question about
wait I thought you'd deny that you had
invited him to him here the way it
always goes is is some version of that
right we hear from the Washington Post
or the New York Times something that
sounds totally nuts then you know Trump
uses his bathtub as a toilet or
something that sounds absolutely nutty
White House immediately condemned says
the president would never use his
bathtub as a toilet it's the fake news
media including that failing fake news
Amazon Jeff Bezos Washington Post
they're smearing the president then like
two days later Trump goes to Twitter and
says hey yeah alright I use my bathtub
as a toilet and Hillary was using her
bath
as a toilet before I did and the FBI
refuses to look into when Hillary
Clinton is using her bathtub as a toilet
no one cares about that and I've been
treated very very unfairly and then the
sort of cherry on top is three days go
by and then Trump says why I never said
I used my bathtub as a toilet I was
misquoted by the loser New York Times I
never said it and then a hundred grand
goes to another pornstar in hush money
and we all forget about it because we're
like ten scandals past it that is the
sort of mo of how these things develop
will we ever hear about it again I
genuinely doubt